have you ever thought about what the
world languages were 1 000 years ago
what influenced language expansion how
the used language or how much advanced
the language was
what the world will speak in 215
so welcome back to language shapes
perception if you're new here and you
like our content make sure to like and
subscribe to our channel
a century from now it's expected to have
fewer but simpler languages on every
continent in 1880 a bavarian priest
created a language that he hoped the
whole world could use he mixed words
from french german and english and gave
his creation the name volapuk which
didn't do it any favors
worse bolepok was hard to use sprinkled
with some odd sounds and case endings
like latin
it made a splash for a few years but was
soon pushed aside by another invented
language esperanto which had a lyrical
name and was much easier to master
a game learner could pick up its rules
of usage in an afternoon
but it didn't matter by the time
esperanto got out of the gate another
language was already emerging as an
international medium english
2000 years ago english was the unwritten
tongue of iron age tribes in denmark
a thousand years after that it was
living in the shadow of french-speaking
overlords on a dampish little island no
one then living could have dreamt that
english would be spoken today to some
degree by almost 2 billion people on its
way to being spoken by every third
person on the planet science fiction
often presents us with whole planets
that speak a single language
but that fantasy seems more menacing
here in real life on this planet we call
home
that is in a world where some worry that
english might eradicate every other
language
the humans can express themselves in
several thousand languages is a delight
in countless ways
few would welcome the loss of this
variety but the existence of so many
languages can also create problems it
isn't an accident that the bible's tale
of the tower of babel presents
multilingualism as a divine curse meant
to hinder our understanding one might
even ask if all humans had always spoken
a single language would anyone wish we
were instead separated now by thousands
of different ones
thankfully fears that english will
become the world's only language are
premature few are so pessimistic as to
suppose that there will not continue to
be a multiplicity of nations and
cultures on our planet and
along with them various languages beside
english
it is difficult after all to interpret
something as intimate and spontaneous as
would language people speak to their
children who truly imagines a japan with
no japanese or greece with no greek
the spread of english just means that
earthlings will tend to use a local
language in their own orbit and english
for communication beyond but the days
when english shared the planet with
thousands of other languages are
numbered
a traveler to the future a century from
now is likely to notice two things about
the language landscape of earth
1. there will be vastly fewer languages
2 languages will often be less
complicated than they are today
especially in how they are spoken as
opposed to how they are written some may
protest that it is not english but
mandarin chinese that will eventually
become the world's language
because of the size of the chinese
population and the increasing economic
might of their nation but that's
unlikely for one english happens to have
gotten there first
it is now so deeply entrenched in print
education and media that switching to
anything else would entail an enormous
effort we retain the qwerty keyboard and
ac current for similar reasons also the
tones of chinese are extremely difficult
to learn beyond childhood
and truly mastering the writing system
virtually requires having been born to
it
in the past of course notoriously
challenging languages such as greek
latin aramaic arabic russian and even
chinese have been embraced by vast
numbers of people
but now that english has settled in its
approachability as compared with chinese
will discourage its replacement
many world power has ruled without
spreading its language and just as the
mongols and manchester once ruled china
while leaving chinese intact if the
chinese rule the world they will likely
do so in english
some have predicted that mandarin
chinese will eventually become the
world's language
but its elaborate tones are too
difficult to learn beyond childhood yet
more to the point by
215 it's possible that only about 600
languages will be left on the planet as
opposed to today's six thousand
japanese will be fine but languages
spoken by smaller groups will have a
hard time of it too often
colonialization has led to the
disappearance of languages
native speakers have been exterminated
or punished for using their languages
this has rendered extinct or moribund
most of the languages of native
americans in north america and
aboriginal people of australia
urbanization has only furthered the
destruction but bringing people away
from their homelands to cities where a
single lingua franca reigns even
literacy despite its benefits can
threaten linguistic diversity to the
modern mind language is used in writing
with its permanence and formality seem
legitimate and real while those that are
only spoken that is
all but a couple hundred of them today
can seem evanescent and parochial few
illusions are harder to shed than the
idea that only writing makes something a
language considered the yiddish is often
described as a dying language at a time
when hundreds of thousands of people are
living and raising children in it just
not writing it much every day in the us
and israel it is easy for speakers to
associate larger languages with
opportunity and smaller ones with
backwardness and therefore to stop
speaking smaller ones to their children
but unless the language is written once
a single generation no longer passes it
on to children whose minds are maximally
plastic it is all but lost we all know
how much harder it is to learn a
language well as adults in a community
where only older people now speak a
language fluently the task is vastly
more difficult than just passing on some
expressions
words and word endings the navajo
language made news recently when a
politician named chris deschen was bare
from leading the navajo nation because
his navajo isn't fluent one wishes mr
deshan well in improving is navajo but
he has a mountain to climb in naval
there is no such thing as a regular verb
you have to learn by hard each variation
of every verb plus it has tones
that's what indigenous languages tend to
be like in one way or another languages
grow in complexity the way that people
pick up habits and cars pick a trust one
minute the way you mark a verb in the
future tense is to use will i will buy
it an idiom kicks in where people say
i'm gonna go buy it or i'm going to buy
it because if you're going with the
purpose of doing something it follows
that you will pretty soon that gels into
a new way of putting a verb in the
future tense with what a martian would
hear as a new word gonna in any
languages that kind of thing is
happening all the time in countless ways
far past what is necessary even for
nuanced communication the distinction
between he and she is a frill that most
languages do without and english would
be fine without gonna alongside will
a language isn't something that can be
trimmed like a bush and children have no
trouble picking up even the weirdest of
linguistic frills
a click language of southern africa
typically has not just two or three but
as many as dozens of different cliques
to master native speakers have a bump on
their larynx from producing them 24 7.
for english speakers it seems hard
enough that mandarin chinese requires
you to distinguish four tones to get
across meaning
but in the hmong languages of southeast
asia any syllable means different things
according to as many as eight tones but
the very things that make these
languages so fabulously rich and also
makes it hard to revive them once lost
it's tough to learn hard stuff when
you're grown busy and self-conscious
there are diligent efforts to keep
various endangered languages from dying
but the sad fact is that few are likely
to lead communities raising children in
the language which is the only way a
language exists as its full self instead
many communities passing their ancestral
language along by teaching it in school
and to adults will create new versions
of the languages with smaller
vocabularies and more streamlined
grammars the irish gaelic proudly spoken
by today's english gaelic bilinguals is
an example of something one might call a
new gaelic new versions of languages
like this will be part of a larger trend
growing over the past few millennia in
particular the birth of language is less
baroquely complicated than the
linguistic norm of the pre-modern world
the first wave in the development
occurred when technology began to allow
massive abrupt population transfers
once large numbers of people could cross
an ocean at one time or be imported by
force into a territory a new language
could end up being learned by hordes of
adults instead of by children as we know
from our experience in the classroom
adults aren't as good at mastering the
details of a language as toddlers are
and the result was simpler languages
vikings for example invaded england
starting in the 8th century and married
into the society children in england
hearing their father's broken old
english in a time when schooling was
limited to elites and there was no media
grew up speaking that kind of english
mandarin persian indonesian and other
languages run through similar processes
and are therefore much less cluttered
than a normal language is now these
languages can express any nuance of
human thought but they haven't existed
long enough to also dangle unnecessary
things like willfully irregular verbs
these are called creole languages it's
far easier to manage a basic
conversation in a creole than in any
older language
haitian creole for example is a language
low on the complications that make
learning navajo or hmong so tough
it spares a student from having to know
that both or male and tablets are female
which is one of the reasons that it's so
hard to master french the language from
which it got most of its word creola
languages were created worldwide during
the era that the textbooks call
western exploration african soldiers
created an arabic crayola in sudan
orphans created a german one in new
guinea aboriginal australians created an
english creole which was passed on to
surrounding locations such as again new
guinea where under the name takbisin
it is today the language of government
for people speaking hundreds of
different native languages jamaican
patois south carolina's gula and cape
verde are other examples modern
population movements are now creating a
third wave of language streamlining
in cities worldwide children of
immigrants speaking many different
languages are growing up speaking among
themselves our version of their new
country's language it's a kind of
compromise between the original version
of the language and the way their
parents speak it linguists have no
single term yet for these new speech
varieties but from kies deutsch in
germany to kebab norsk in norway from
the urban wall of senegal to singapore
singlish the world is witnessing the
birth of lightly optimized versions of
old languages this streamlining should
not be taken as a sign of decline
all of the optimized languages remain
full languages in every sense of the
term as we know from the fact that i'm
writing in one an old english speaker
who heard modern english would consider
it confounding and broken that any
language has all irregular verbs eight
tones or female tables is ultimately a
matter of accident not design hopefully
the languages lost amid all of this
change will at least be described and
with modern tools recorded for posterity
we may regret the eclipse of a world
where 6 000 different languages were
spoken as opposed to just 600 but there
is a silver lining in the fact that ever
more people will be able to communicate
in one language that they use alongside
their native one after all what's
peculiar about the babel tale is the
idea of linguistic diversity as a curse
not the idea of universal comprehension
as a blessing the future promises both a
goodly amount of this diversity
and ever more mutual comprehension as
many languages become easier to pick up
in their spoken versions that they once
were a future dominated by english won't
be a linguistic paradise but it won't be
a linguistic armageddon either
[Music]
[Music]
studying language is a privilege when
you analyze language in everyday speech
you realize that there is an astonishing
amount of wonder in the system that we
take for granted
linguists question the obvious which is
language
and god answers that forever change
mankind's understanding of language and
human nature
we all speak one language
one of the main discoveries of modern
linguistics is that it made us aware
that all the languages we speak are
similar in astonishing respects they
manifest the same pattern follow the
same rules they are learned in the
exactly same way and that all the
differences are only superficial so in a
sense we all speak the same language
this was captured by chomsky in an
excellent metaphor titled language and
mind
in which he says that if a martian
scientist somebody with a different kind
of intelligence were to study the
world's languages
he would conclude that they are all
dialects of a single language embodying
a universal grammar reflecting a
hard-wired genetically determined
linguistic module inherent in the human
brain
a studies of topologically different
languages show that this is indeed the
case i will mention in passing one of
probably the main arguments used to
prove this take a child that was born in
china and have him raised in saudi
arabia and hill grove speaking arabic
what does that say to you it says that a
human child is hardwired to learn any
languages and that all human languages
say mandarin and arabic in this case are
fundamentally the same if they weren't
the task of child to learn any language
would be impossible
this has massive implications the
greatest of which is that all the 7 000
human languages have the same source and
that every language spoken today evolved
from the same great great great
grandmother tongue another implication
is that if a martian would fly past our
planet he would hear japanese and ojibwe
like we hear british and american
english this is an interesting line of
thought if you want to read more about
it i got a good book you could read it's
called chomsky's universal grammar and
introduction part 2 language change is
natural
people so often combat language change
and are feared by it linguists know that
natural language change is not bad for a
language
adopting long words from other languages
losing inflection cases genders articles
and formally distinct sounds this
happens in all languages and is nothing
to worry about for linguists it's an
interesting phenomenon worth analyzing
for some people it's proof for the
demise of language the end of civilized
culture and the beginning of the dying
of the proper language but languages
constantly change and this is certainly
not how languages die
too many people fear language change
many people think that if we don't
attempt to regulate the correct form of
speaking from spelling to pronunciation
to word choice then we will all plunge
into anarchy or some sort of misfortune
it's sham
language constantly evolves and even
those political or cultural elites who
claim to use it correctly fail to do so
themselves and even those who fancy
themselves as guardians of the correct
way of speaking can even agree on
whether split infinitives are kosher
society is a rise and fall but not
because too many people started to say
ain't when they should have said isn't
part three there are no bad grammars
one of the things you know when you
start studying languages is that you
realize how stupid is the claim that
says there are bad grammars linguists
know that all dialects even those
considered bad grammar by many people
are as fully formed and rule-bound as
any other language
someone who uses appalachian dialect or
african-american vernacular english to
use two united states examples is not
simply ignorant of grammatical roles
taught in school or speaking sloppily
they are following a different set of
roles which are consistent within their
own dialect sometimes the linguistic
complexity of languages associated with
underprivileged societies and that we
call bad grammars far exceeds that of
modern and privileged societies
william lapov in fact analyzed
african-american vernacular english and
showed us that it is a beautiful
language with a sophisticated structure
and has many features that standard
english lacks
you can read more about this lava's own
book titled language in the inner city
studies in the black english vernacular
part 4
there are monolingual linguists
i don't know how to stress this further
being a linguist does not equal being a
polyglot
while it's true that linguists study all
languages this does not mean that they
engage in learning them they only study
them to test certain hypotheses related
to how languages work linguists know
that there are monolingual linguists
there are even linguists who advise
against learning languages seriously
people should stop using linguist and
polyglot or language lover synonymously
the surest way to annoy a linguist is to
ask so how many languages do you speak
part five
language is fractal
languages know that you really can't
fully describe any human language it
seems to be impossible to produce enough
rules to fully describe any natural
language you always find that there are
wild expressions that your rules forbid
and invalid expressions that your roles
permit that's what we mean when we say
all grammars leak
of course you can create new rules to
cover those exceptions but teams have
spent decades at this without closing
all the holes despite creating tens of
thousands of roles
this is one reason linguists have
trouble taking grammar perspectivists
seriously we know that no description of
grammar small enough to fit in a single
volume can be anything more than a set
of guidelines part 6 monoglots can
become polyglots linguists know that
everybody who speaks one language can
learn others if they want to
the mathematics behind linguistics for
example automata theory and chomsky's
hierarchy of languages indicate that an
astonishing amount of intelligence is
required to become a monoglot the more
we study computational linguistics the
automata theory the more we understand
this the simplest theoretical machine
that could accurately parse a human
language and map to meanings would be
incredibly complex surprisingly the
amount of complexity one must add in
order to parse a second language is
almost negligible in other words there
is no real difference in the
intelligence necessary to become a
monoglot or a polyglot
perceived differences in difficulty have
more to do with learning as an adult
versus as a child during the critical
period and with the enjoyment of
learning and willingness to work
i'm sure linguists know so much more
that can be said in the video language
changed our perceptions about language
changed the way we regard minority
languages and most importantly linguists
made us aware that no language is
inferior join the bandwagon to recognize
the efforts of linguists by subscribing
to this channel and sharing this video
language is one of the fundamental
dynamics in the composition of a culture
the power of a nation
is directly proportional to the power
and richness of its language and thought
a perfect command of language and the
ability to engage easily in dialogue
with others protect a person from
outside influence
language is an important tool for
humankind in our efforts to better
understand the cosmos and events both
holistically and analytically from every
aspect language plays a defining role in
the formation of our culture
language is not only a means of speech
and thought
it is a bridge with the significant
function of bringing the wealth of the
past to our day and conveying today's
heritage and our new compositions to the
future
all of the cognitive intellectual and
scientific reserves and riches of a
nation can become eternal only by means
of a language powerful enough to embrace
this heritage as a whole
a heritage that has descended from the
ancestors and taken new forms in the
hands of today's generations the more
richly and colorfully a nation can speak
the more they can think the more they
can think the broader is the span their
speech can reach
every single society leaves behind what
they speak and think today for its
validity to be probed tested and
protected by future generations
in this way a huge reserve of experience
and learning are saved from being wasted
what was right or wrong in the past is
compared with the rights and wrongs of
today so that we do not treat the same
path and suffer from the same errors
this is valid for all nations of the
world the capacity of a language to
express a thought is related to the
level of development it has achieved and
a thought can become the instrument by
which the language is tuned to this
level of development
if a language has not developed with its
inner dynamics to voice the needs of all
times and therefore the users of that
language cannot find the words
corresponding to certain concepts then
that language is deprived of the support
of thought
and its users are doomed to failure
in a time of industrialization global
commerce and technological warehouses no
one should stay within the limited span
of dictionaries in hand or what they
hear and learn from the people around
them
otherwise they will have to remain
silent and merely listen to what others
have to say
such difference to the requirements of
the modern age leads to disqualification
from participation in contemporary
societies
the earnings of yesterday should be
conserved as a cultural heritage and
utilized today
historical and social dynamics are
threats with which national ideas should
be interlaced
by all means this should be realized
while opening up to tomorrow and
embracing the modern age
as a matter of fact yesterday has passed
with all its frame of reference what is
more
reaching out to the future at full speed
requires much more sustenance than we
can draw from our homes family and
immediate environment
though they may suffice for a practical
daily needs
failure is the inescapable end of the
ill-fated and forlorn ones who are far
from facing their era with their own
language and thought
just as important as ensuring language
and thoughts survive is making them a
property of the masses
societies which do not think and speak
will find others speak and think on
their behalf
logic is in disposal of the tongue in
crowds where there is speech without
thought
those unfortunate ones who cannot put
what they think into words are slaves of
their incapability
although not in great numbers there are
still self-confident thinkers who can
elaborate their thoughts nevertheless
they too are not free from problems in
many countries those who look like the
elite from the outside are in truth
alien to their own society the majority
in their society respond to this elite
with an inner opposition for they do not
trust them and their thoughts are
perceived as nothing more than mere
fantasy and important views
you find the prose of these
intellectuals written in their own
language but with the mindset of an
alien and when they have to speak they
feel the need to switch to the
vernacular of their fellow countrymen
thus they're traveling between several
worlds in their inner presence
in a state of multiple belongings to
different realms at the same time
they cannot adjust their hearts to be in
tune with the heart of their society
nor can they reflect the pattern of
eloquence
and power of expression embedded in
their language
it would be naive to expect some sort of
valuable service from such people who
are entrapped in contradictions within
their personal world of thought
for language truly to become the medium
of communication the overwhelming
majority of a society must be able to
express themselves in it with full
command and reflecting its true nature
expressions in a complicated way like
loading the real intention to diverse
illusions or signs and relaying every
subject in the form of detailed
interpretations are obviously not the
most agreeable types of presentation
language is a phenomenon the worth of
which lies intrinsically in itself like
other sciences and perhaps its
importance
is even of a greater magnitude
thus any society should conceive of its
language as a field of knowledge and the
interest of the masses must be drawn to
it as a pleasurable topic
this is possible only by way of a long
list of tasks to do with language
a successful compilation of every single
word a careful study of manuscripts a
deep analysis of the methodology and
stylistics of derivative forms in
harmony with the peculiar nature of a
language to make widely known and used
those words and idioms that have been in
use over many centuries firmly settled
with all their nuances and with their
specific meanings revealed best in that
language
it is of a paramount importance for a
nation to be respectful towards all
these components of preserving a
language if all these can be achieved
then a language can stand on its own
principles and roles as rich
soft and amiable as a language can be
a language can become the lingua franca
of an age while maintaining its inherent
logic it will be in use delightfully and
will be transferred from one generation
to the next
although this expectation does not seem
theoretically or logically exaggerated
it is not easy to realize it there will
be challenges while putting it into
practice
something being logical might not always
mean the same thing as the logic of its
development transformation and
maturation
the unfolding of events may follow a
different path
in the case of constant change the logic
of development must be given priority
above absolute logic the rains
controlling it must be loosed a little
and space from maneuver must be enlarged
if not language and thought both living
phenomena will become stagnant
as solidified as rock and will lose
their soul
language has a determining influence on
the national thought and worldview and
their logical intellectual structure
language has to be in its prime to go
beyond historical value and respond
positively to every favorable
development
nations that can manage to develop their
language and make it accommodating while
at the same time staying faithful to the
roots of it are the most communicative
societies that are also most dynamic in
thought
the relationship between language and
thought comprises cognitive and
intellectual reflections on existence
and events
transforming these reflections into
sources of information and becoming
productive while forming links between
the cosmos and our knowledge
the future prospects of a nation are
very much dependent on evaluating these
relationships
we should not cast everything that is
old into oblivion
nor turn our face to the past and close
our doors to what is new let us embrace
the past with the outmost sincerity and
at the same time salute the coming days
with their open new developments and
transformations
let us not cause any conflict between
language and thought between our past
that is filled with exalted memories and
our future that we strive so hard for
let us not sacrifice one for the other
the roots that make up the national
spirit should be determined with the
help of research
while relying firmly on those roads a
society should endeavor to go beyond
them
our hearts should be connected to our
essential dynamics of our spiritual
heritage and our eyes should be fixed
beyond the horizon we should aim to live
and flourish with an insatiable thing
for opening out
this is how it can be possible to make
future generations survive
[Music]
those generations to whose sake we
should bind our existence
it must be those selfless men and women
who are devoted to making other lives
and expect nothing in return who cherish
this life best with its all possible
dimensions
[Music]
you